it's almost Valentine's Day which may
mean you're splashing out on flowers or
dates but after all the wining and
dining you might find yourself longing
to play a video game with a roommate
significant other friend or a casual
acquaintance that's a great idea
but you might want to make sure you play
the right one here's my list of great
co-op games to play this Valentine's Day
and also some games that have serious
potential to spoil the mood so watch out
this isn't a statement on the quality of
the games but rather a judgment on the
likelihood that you'll have fun and not
end up in a fight let's start with a
great game portal 2 in co-op yep
sometimes if it ain't broke there's no
need to fix it this puzzle game may be
almost 10 years old but it has an
excellent co-op mode with custom maps
cute characters and a ping system so the
more puzzle adept of you doesn't end up
losing their patience with the other one
too badly portal 2 co-op is charming
unique and reasonably simple to drop
into for all levels of gamer and non
gamer alike because of the way levels
are designed you'll always feel like you
contributed to the end goal in an
important way which is a fantastic
feeling that you won't necessarily get
in unravel - oh boy if you seriously
want to play unravel - with another
person I suggest you rethink you're
connected by string the entire time
which can mean if you're trying to
execute something your partner can mess
up and really back in not give you
enough rope or just prevent you from
moving forward unravel - is also harder
than the first game and requires more
platforming know-how as well as puzzling
know how you have to get the timing just
right and make sure you don't muddle
your buttons and drop your yarn friend
at an inopportune moment luckily you can
absorb your partner incomplete levels
alone which I appreciate it as a drink
break but it certainly doesn't make you
feel like your presence is required if
you and your chosen gaming pallor
platforming fans this is a great choice
but if not maybe try out army of - okay
now bear with me I know this one is 12
years old and you will need a ps3 or an
xbox because it is available with
backwards compatibility but trust me
it's worth it you'll step into the shoes
of either Tyson or Elliot and embark
upon a shoot-'em-up romp as two private
contractors tasked with executing a
handful of deadly important mission
you'll help each other through the
campaign in all its split-screen glory
in a shooter designed to be played with
the partner upgrade your gear in
weaponry and eventually get enough cash
to pimp out your guns in a not at all
covert gold which was probably my
favorite part army of two is constant
fun without the headache unlike
overcooked
- now I'm advising against this one
because I assume you and your gaming pal
are not digital Pro cooking enthusiasts
who thrive under mounting pressure if
you are go ahead and throw out
overcooked - if you're not I will tell
you from experience that overcooked it
destroys working relationships and
friendships if you're not on the same
page one person wants to designate
meticulously planned orders to help
things along one person keeps falling
off the edge of the damn kitchen and one
jackass just won't stop messing with the
fire extinguisher if you haven't noticed
from my tone the Australian office only
played overcooked a handful of times
before deciding our working
relationships couldn't take it on the
opposite end of the spectrum is office
favorite keep talking and nobody
explodes the strategic bomb defusal game
always makes an appearance during our
Extra Life charity streams and it's
great for all kinds of players one
person leaves through the lengthy bomb
defusal manual while the other does
their best to describe the bomb they're
looking at and its various diffusal
components no peeking I'll be honest you
might get yelled at at some point for
some poor explaining but there is a true
feeling of accomplishment when you get
the hang of the game in its quirks and
it's one of the few games that doesn't
require anyone to know video game basics
or how to use a controller this one is
practically a relationship building
exercise and it's a snap to learn the
basics
unlike divinity original sin - now look
I love this game
I've been quoted as saying it's one of
the best RPGs of this century but if I
tried to get my non-gaming pal to sit
down with me on a Friday evening and
play a wildly dense RPG it would not go
well that's before you explain the law
the term based systems and how there's
little room for error because if they
mess up with their character they're
probably gonna mess up your entire
party's meticulously planned combat
encounter puzzle solving attempt or
dialogue exchange adding to the
potential nightmare is original sin
tooth emphasis on decision making the
that you can miss entire conversations
and quests if you split up and loot
doesn't duplicate nope for a breezy
v-day session what you really want is a
linear game what you really want is a
way out a way out is an excellent co-op
game designed from the ground up to be
played split-screen with another person
you'll each have your own character
things to do puzzles to solve and agency
to explore without the risk of
everything going belly-up when somebody
makes a mistake it cleverly balances
tension silliness and story and though
the narrative and dialogue are not
flawless it's seriously fun when you've
got a buddy to help you break out of a
digital prison that is right up until
the last 20 minutes of a way out that's
it that's the last game on the list the
last 20 minutes of the game before the
last game on the list a way out is a
blast the whole way through and nurse
spoilers here but look if you're a
bigger person than me this might not be
such a problem for you but for me the
last 20 minutes of a way out is the most
relationships training experience I've
ever had with a video game if you've
played it yourself head over to Twitter
and tell me about it because I cannot
imagine finishing that game and not
being in an argument first 5 hours
though brilliant just turn it off before
the end at least on date night trust me
let me know what your favorite cult game
is down in that comment section and
leave me your picks for the best and
worst game to play with the significant
other
[Music]
you